We have a band called racket,
which,
uh,
it's a rock and roll band and it was set
up by myself and a fellow called Nigel
Smith who's a scholar of English
literature in particular a marvel and
Milton.
He does some work and him used to teach
at Oxford.
I met him in Oxford actually when I was
a professor poetry at Oxford and he was
the head of the English department at
Oxford United Teachers at Princeton.
So He's,
he's a very,
very
serious scholar,
but behind it all he's a rocker.
And um,
so he and I got together and we started.
I have always been interested in trying
to write songs I just
would love to be able to do it was quite
a difficult thing to do also.
But anyway,
we got together and we set up with a
band,
been a couple of versions of it,
but the present version of a great
guitarist and lead singer called Matthew
as a music scholar.
Um,
and then,
uh,
we have,
Steven Alan who's an entertainment
lawyer,
but a trained musician,
one of the Berkeley College of music.
And then our drummer,
Bobby Lewis as a also studied music at,
uh,
the College of New Jersey,
Trenton.
So they're all,
they're all quite wonderful musicians.
But this bit's rock'n'roll.
So rock and roll with the way.
Hope you know,
Demi,
Sammy,
Tammy semi.
Interesting.
Merrick's we're hoping.
We're hoping that's the idea.
So that combination and uh,
you know,
we keep plugging away at it.
And a
no,
we do it for fun to a large extent,
but we also were somewhat areas,
not in the sense that we're expected who
playing Madison Square Garden any day
soon though.
Mind you if there's anyone from Madison
Square Garden listening,
you know,
you should think about is um,
and um,
you know,
we have to be realistic about that.
Uh,
I,
I suppose that a fixed but 56 year old
like myself shouldn't be cherishing even
the remotest notion of that.
But then I think Mick Jagger,
Mick Jagger's in slightly better shape
than I am as A.
Anyway,
I'm back to the treadmill.
I write the lyrics.
That's my main role.
I write the lyrics and I play the odd
some sometimes ms dot calculated chord
on a guitar,
but you know,
I do so with Breo or certainly the
attempt,
the attempt a of a Breo.
I love it.
I mean it's just,
it's so much fun.
It's so much fun.
And the band actually is great.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's the standard one side.
We're praising myself,
but I'd said they're quite brilliant
really.